a team of incompetence that's the focus
of tonight's angle
this is a defining moment in the chaos
that this that is this presidency the
reputation of the united states has
created i've never seen an instance when
the president is so detached from the
reality of what's going on it's a slow
motion disaster machine
well they worked overtime to brand the
trump white house as out of control from
day one
time magazine inside donald trump's
white house chaos the guardian chaos in
the white house there's never been
anything like this
yeah when the media cried chaos what
they really were expressing was fear
now why fear
they knew trump was going to do what he
promised to do during the campaign in
other words take the country in a new
populist direction in other words a gut
punch to the old establishment both
parties
unlike so many others
trump just wasn't willing to play the
old game of media patty cake in exchange
for more favorable coverage from them
so they set the stage for the completely
bogus russia collusion investigation
the targeting of michael flynn
the phony claims of racism the sham
impeachment proceedings and much much
more
and because of that wildly biased
reporting most of what americans saw
during the trump years was a swirl of
controversy
yet now
look at where we are america is truly in
danger under a president who is
physically and mentally deteriorating
before our eyes
and real chaos and i mean real is
unfolding
food and fuel prices are devouring
family budgets
schools are under siege by radical
anti-american forces
inflation spinning ever higher and
democrats just recklessly try to spend
and borrow even more money in order to
grow the government
all of which means you'll have to get
used to a lower standard of living
now chaos is inevitable
when you assemble a team of incompetence
people chosen not because of the most
experience for the job
but because they check the diversity
equity and inclusion box
even cnn had to admit what we warned
about last spring
kamala harris is floundering
writing harris is struggling with a
rocky relationship with some parts of
the white house
while long-time supporters feel
abandoned and see no coherent public
sense of what she's done or been trying
to do as vice president
defenders and people who care for harris
are getting frantic
then there was jen saki's sunday night
desperate tweet defending harris as a
quote vital partner and quote bold
leader
which of course only made matters worse
literally there is no human being on
earth right now who's thinking
thank god kamala is there working with
biden because she's a bold leader
now they've had to do similar propping
up of diversity cabinet pick pete
buttige who took two months off during a
crisis
he's such a lightweight the
administration had to pull in former new
orleans mayor mitch landrieu to oversee
the spending of their phony
infrastructure bill
because when i think of new orleans i
think of smart budget priorities
and then low energy secretary jennifer
granholm who needs to buy a vowel on gas
prices
the president is all over this the
president is looking at the limited
tools that he has i have nothing to
announce on this but no he is looking
and evaluating
all of his options uh limited though
they may be in the united states
are they looking into the oatmeal bowl
what it means looking into what's he
looking into go to the gas pump you have
to look into it it's like 475 a gallon
in dc
it's one incompetent after another
blinking
at the state department looks like a
fawn
in the spotlight who lost his mother
and let's not forget john kerry who's
now in a position of outsized authority
ready willing and able to give china
whatever it wants for vague assurances
on climate goals
then general mark milley secretary of
defense austin they're still bumbling
about looking for extremists in our own
ranks that's our biggest threat still no
accountability for 13 dead americans or
the 120 000 unvetted afghans who are
flooding our communities as a result of
the half-cocked withdrawal they did from
afghanistan
and we don't need to remind you of the
infuriating performance of secretary
mayorkas at homeland security who just
has no intention of stopping the flow of
illegals swarming our border
an overrun border remember
is the biden administration's policy
well secretary of treasury janet yellen
she's now just making stuff up
the pandemic has been calling the shots
for the economy and for inflation i
think it's it's it's important to
realize that the cause of this inflation
is the pandemic
is this her way of admitting that
inflation won't be temporary because the
virus isn't going anywhere anytime soon
clearly
and one of the dimmest of bulbs in a
drawer of low wattage intellects is
biden's chief economic advisor ryan
deese
we know that the more that people feel
comfortable getting out into the economy
going to movies rather than buying a
television at home working in the
workplace the more we can return a sense
of normalcy to our economy getting those
shots out for five to eleven-year-olds
is going to provide a lot of comfort to
american families we're making a lot of
progress on that front
what is it wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait is he not aware of the fact
that red state america florida idaho
tennessee
has pretty much been back to normal for
most of the past year when zero five to
11 year olds were vaccinated
frankly the only part of biden's
administration that seems to be making
an effort is the calm shop
every day they're out trying to sell
sand in the desert
we look at uh most of these data points
through the prism of covid
and we know that we were in this the in
this place we are in now
because of covid because of the impact
of the pandemic
now you might not be able to buy many
christmas gifts this year but biden just
signed into law a new government slush
fund for democrats to direct toward
their friends and cronies
this law was supported by business
groups the u.s chamber of commerce
organized labor who understands this
about jobs special thanks to the afl-cio
the united auto workers the liquid
workers the ibw the iron workers it goes
on who would i leave out pardon me
[Music]
and my wife is a member of the union the
nea i'm gonna get in trouble
but the real question is what does corn
pop think
the internal chaos might not be reported
on much but the voters know what's
happening the havoc the biden
administration has caused in 10 short
months is astounding
but he had a lot of help from the most
incompetent white house team in history
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else